wir haben so drei dinge die wir beachten
müssen einerseits noch dieses mal schnee
handtuch sieht so ein bisschen so aus
wie das dann anschauen
wir müssen offen auf eine problematische
lage an der ostsee gleich eingeht und
sibirien feeling in den nächsten tagen
also die drei themen erst mal dass
schnee handtuch ja wir haben immer noch
so ein bisschen schnee in berlin und
brandenburg ist steigt auch in den
nächsten stunden noch das wird in der
nacht weniger das kann ich schon
versprechen es wird dann besser aber
noch ist das nicht durch man sieht ist
immer noch hier niederschlag das gleiche
für sie für das südliche niedersachsen
theresa auch da immer noch leichter
schneefall
das gleiche für den niederrhein die
münsteraner die haben überhaupt keine
lust mehr auf schnee die können das
nicht mehr sehen auch da immer noch so
ein bisschen schnee aber dann verspreche
ich auch es wird in der nacht nach
lassen es wird besser
harz auch noch weiter schnee sachsen
anhalt noch so ein bisschen auch da im
laufe der nacht dann etwas besserung die
gute nachricht ist der wind ist da auch
schon schwächer mit den
schneeverwehungen ist das jetzt nicht
mehr so ein großes problem
und jetzt theresa denke ich mal müssen
wir die ostseeküste darauf vorbereiten
schneeschippe schauen aber bereit halten
macht er da eigentlich eher ungewöhnlich
ja also in normale die letzten winter
nicht das große thema
und da schauen wir uns mal ganz kurz an
in der eine prognose was da morgen früh
passiert also vielleicht gibt es mir
noch mal den stift weiß ja ich mal so
gerne mache es jetzt auch noch mal der
mal genau also es geht um den bereich
von kiel lübecker morgen unbedingt
vorbei 5 bis 10 cm morgen im
tagesverlauf 10 cm schnee es geht dann
weiter rostock bis stralsund dann auch
der der ganz rügen davon betroffen
starker wind immer wieder schneefall
das ist die lage von der der
verkehrsminister eben sprach die sehr
sehr problematisch sein kann weil du
hast schneeschauer die durchziehen dann
hast du auflebende wind der winterdienst
räumt genau die situation die wir jetzt
in ostwestfalen hat der winter den
freund die straße es weht wieder zu der
nächste schnee schauer kommt rein also
sehr guten ruhigen 10 bis 20 zentimeter
neuschnee aber die verwiegung die machen
es dann nochmal also rügen rüber dieser
bereich bis kiel etwa es kann auch sein
dass der schnee sogar ein bisschen
richtung hamburg nicht so stark aber
auch da rein
und auch später die nordseeküste ist
auch so ein bisschen dabei allerdings
nicht so schlimm wie die ostsee da würde
ich sagen sehr im august vor sehr im
auge behalten was da passiert oben hat
also sozusagen morgen das ist morgen der
hotspot die die ostseeküste mit bewegung
und dann auch wahrscheinlich am mittwoch
also das ist nicht so schnell vorbei der
donnerstag sogar möglicherweise rein
darauf achten also das könnte
problematisch kälte sibiriens fehling
und ganz ganz wichtig wir haben hier
schon die temperaturen morgen früh
münster - 16 grad in der prognose und
das ist die lufttemperatur am boden über
dem schnee kann es teilweise noch kälter
sein
hannover - 14 grad berlin war - 10
muss das wirklich schon sagen - 10 im
verhältnis halle - 15
wir haben den frost jetzt übrigens auch
dann weiter nach süden schon mal leicht
aber immerhin er ist jetzt da auch
freiburg im breisgau morgen - 1 - 1 grad
in münchen also die kälte es auch so ein
bisschen dann nach süden weiter
vorangekommen
aber ich sag nochmal dieses sibirien
viel und look für die nächsten tage für
deutschland wie kriegen unglaubliche
kälte teilweise minus 20 -25 grad in
ungünstigen lagen im erzgebirge weise
wir kennen das in sachsen an vielen
stellen wo kälte löcher sind kann es
auch noch darunter gehen in den städten
die ihr immer so ein bisschen wärmer
sind kassel am mittwochmorgen 20
donnerstagmorgen - 17
selbst der wilderei - 10 11 grad also
wirklich frost den wir hier eigentlich
gar nicht kennen
auch das wurde ja schon von reportern
gesprochen bitte nicht auf eisflächen
jetzt gehen man denkt ja das hält es ist
ja einmal kalt genug
jasid sie klassen hat lust dazu ich
verstehe die kinder aber das ist alles
noch da drunter ist der boden zum teil
warm unter dem schnee und auch das
wasser ist noch warm wir hatten ja zum
teilen milden winter gehabt so und
deswegen das ist noch zu früh es kann
sein dass im laufe des februars dann das
vielleicht so zufriert dass man darauf
gehen kann aber bitte das jetzt nicht
machen die tragödie ist ganz dramatisch
also aus meteorologischer sicht sind die
gewässer auf gar keinen fall stabil das
ist noch viel zu dünn und das muss noch
viel mehr ferien also bitte das und auf
jeden fall unterlassen trotzdem hammer
kälte und nochmals schnee an der
ostseeküste ordentlich
tja patricia die aussichten ja wir haben
es gehört wir sollten uns am besten in
den nächsten tagen ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz dick einpacken und an der ostsee am
besten überhaupt nicht mehr vor die tür
denn da wird heftig schneien
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren